if he dies at any point in any fashion
we are moving on to doom 2016 so you die
right here we go to doom don't say that
what oh is he one of the prophets okay
Luke got you right that count I don't
know it doesn't count
I need a poll does that count is Robin
out or we'll move on or can they revive
him yeah you didn't die like technically
yeah okay all right well great
oh hello if in the interest of keeping
more tensed you want to get rid of
companions from here on out yeah that's
okay okay so you state you stick to the
woods you run the higher chance of
running into animals I could outrun a
bear yeah I think in this game you can
[Laughter]
you make it no did you lose him don't
turn around just keep running all right
so I throw it you'll die in this cave
all right so I throw it and like right
here and then lure him out and then wait
for him to come out of the cave we got
ourselves a little bit of a plan here I
don't like this at all now I'm all hi
[Music]
you tough did you get him
oh yeah you just read this appliance I
should do that yes bride the ziplines
that seems easy enough
ambience oh no way
oh my god no don't you had four welcome
back to grave hoppers job yeah that's a
bummer we screwed up I messed up four
minutes left didn't go so well
we're here with doom today we're here
with two I'll explain the shell for
those who live anew yeah we'll explain
the show
this is grave robbers when we put one
life in every game perma death you die
in one game you move on to the next last
week was far cry 5 I died mm-hmm in the
end trying to be cool I'm trying to
survive for one hour today if I get to
what like 306 p.m. Pacific that's right
I continued with doom next week at the
same time that it I move on to we move
on to halo combat Evolved so we have
that currently booted up halo is ready
to go as is Dark Souls technically in
case we really suck tonight yeah so
there it is the score there
I really [ __ ] if we get to Dark Souls we
might have to worry about the last of us
because I don't know how long I I'm
decent at Dark Souls but there's the
asylum demon could still screw me up
yeah either way I'll survive to him for
an hour today and we won't through I
think you will cuz we did a little like
test run of the show and the early
phases and you got pretty far yeah that
wasn't live though I'm gonna load it up
right now
so go for it cool here we are again if I
die at all today
I'm done with doom then I give the
controller or Rob picks up this Xbox
controller on this Xbox one X no Xbox
one that we have ready yeah it's an Xbox
one it's actually the master no it's the
halo 5 Xbox yeah so it's real cool
inappropriate all right so where we left
off actually you were probably like 4
minutes in you're in that like the fate
I want to say the stage right after you
get shotgun right yeah I just got the
combat shotgun right there's two
shotguns or it might have autosave right
before I got the shotgun meeting there I
got the combat shotgun
but I have a pistol yeah and this is the
hardest possible difficult oh there we
go
this is the hardest possible difficulty
available to us right now once you beat
the game you get the harder difficulty
but this is the ultraviolence so a
couple hits and I'm dead a few hits men
dead let me react them alright alright
it's our one switches weapons didn't do
any any training last night no no I told
I promise people I'm like wheat sub-code
no I play this game enough that I was
got the muscle oh [ __ ] one of these
things already I mean I had me I had to
like play some Far Cry on hard just to
get a feel for it I'm gonna get armor
make sure I'm ready for this [ __ ] should
I should turn the sensitivity down a
little bit I think do what no I need is
I need this alright don't have the
double jump yet forget about that I've
been playing a lot of Ghost Recon oddly
enough lately so I'm it's not reloading
it's gonna be weird not having a reload
option it's kind of nice yeah yeah
alright kill you guys so for those of
you just joining us this is yeah uh
blows no I don't want those to screw me
up in during during combat I don't want
those to come back and bite me in the
butt so again this is this is show
called grave hoppers will we put perma
death in every game so if Mike dies in
dune we move on to another game and then
I ex care with me for a second no you're
good a next game would be halo original
combat Evolved not anniversary original
so is this nightmare mode I think this
is no this is ultraviolence
ultraviolence do you have to unlock
nightmare I think after completing
completing an ultra-light I think you
just be done any difficulty Mew get it
there we go
let me clear these guys out party the
Gorn nest all right wait I didn't see
our people expecting me to die did I
don't know uh oh you did see some of
that right I didn't see any of it okay
now here we go
first Gorn s let's see how I do public
line press 1 in chat if you think Mike's
gonna die today - if you think he'll
live I'm not seeing any twos Shh
so I feel 306 that's right
306 and and we call it for the day
there's a hit so your first hit yeah
these guys would be good at dodgeball
they are good at dodgeball
yeah those hits are doing you sent
amount of damage to me but Jay says
you're gonna die in less than five
minutes I think that's a little you know
who I am
just kidding there's an L a kuriboh says
to Chris says to oh yeah I got some
believers I believe in you some help oh
I love I love getting help when you
don't do that glory kills just little
bonus Chamorro says to for good luck
Jack Reed says to do I had a secondary
shot with this yet yep don't really
necessarily need it oh I killed him that
was anticlimactic anybody anybody
anybody where's this catastrophic says
27 minutes it's very specific
Oh dark is that like a James Franco
version of oh [ __ ] I've learned this the
hard way that was weird
yeah sweet first Gorn s not too much
trouble
I forgot about these yeah when Rob and I
were piloting the show I yeah we didn't
even close to dying with a from
explosive barrels several times you got
to keep an eye out for those red barrels
for sure the oldest video game tropes
Olivia
I really want to replay this game it's
gonna walk well you'll get to watch the
whole thing here on this show we want to
yeah
don't can't be serious I'm serious
you're good but Samuel Hayden what a
jerk just cracking my bionic knuckles Oh
forgot we weren't even technically been
there yet and yet my butt is tense it's
not what I meant to say okay yeah Mars
you're on Mars
just a reminder for those who's joining
us we put permadeath in every game so
right now we're on doom I I died I had a
real real crap run in Far Cry 5 that was
it was it was it was exciting
yeah you lent some drama oh there's no
following game in this game okay cool
yeah you're good
oh Jesus that still scared me then we
got halo after this I'll be playing that
yeah could be today could be six weeks
from now the one game in this list I'm
dreading is alien isolation
I am too I don't know how far you'll get
in that I'm afraid to watch that
yeah so we were talking with Tay our
producer before director you might say
before this one live today there is some
platforming this game that has screwed
me up in the past
I don't refer I think that's actually
one of the weaker aspects of this
fantastic game yeah but that might be
the thing to finish me off if I get that
far I remember playing this game and
dying a few times on that platforming
session is but one with the bridge right
it's like there's there's a cup catwalk
yet yeah I'd say was saying the t1000
Easter Egg is on that mission and then
I'm also gonna try to conserve you get a
pretty decent mount amel in this game
you also get a rocket launcher and your
main rotation so I'm sure I'll be fine
use such a fear for red bag I don't
believe me on this difficulty that I
used to be close to him or you could be
semi close and they would just wreck me
I'm gonna help but I'll still do that
anyways just fun and I get people in
ability key person triangle to switch
weapon still
I like that one he just punches his
spine can't remember the name of the
monster demon taco the floating one more
than big the behemoth thing slugger
good one a charges at you you like was
born already yeah I should know that
yeah
maybe someone to chat with no he's like
he's like one of the iconic yeah it's
escaping escape
I love how the projectiles in this game
move like slow enough to dodge but still
pretty quick yeah sweet alright full
health almost full health please you got
a checkpoint but you're never gonna use
it no I know just that just occurred to
me those don't matter halo that would be
are you doing halo on legendary or did
we decide that legendary well on the lid
I've forgot no I forgot I was gonna do
heroic but I think we'll just do
legendary I know where I'm gonna die
hey library no no even earlier there is
this area that I just like had a real
tough time with it's it's actually the
second mission mission where you land
you know the first two banshees kind of
stocky you can sprint past those guys if
there's a first outpost with like a
bunch of Marines yeah and like become
innocent in a bunch of drop ships I just
had a tough time there oh I forget I
have grenades in this game with a
[ __ ] rocket launcher might yeah l1
I hope sweet nice throw
I'm trying not to play well I mean this
game we figured this is like tailor-made
for the show because they it designed it
so you have to keep me at four where
else where's getting messed up yeah and
I have like no choice almost yeah nor to
get ammo and health and I don't know you
don't get shield from enemies too you
know that usually it picked up you just
get you get health from glory kills ammo
from chainsaw kills and then you're just
a fine chainsaw the fuel yeah
I feel like I'm using a lot of shocking
but I don't think I'll get enough
it's the game is pretty plentiful mo
people keep mentioning knack - I can't
tell for serious uh yeah heroic is my
favorite way to play Halo but I don't
think I've ever beaten the Halo game on
her like win one life I don't think I've
I mean legendary you have to especially
right can't on Halo two got away did
away with the whole if you want if he
dies you both go back to the last
checkpoint which I didn't like I don't
know did they rectify that and uh he
look to anniversary or no halo one
anniversary or hello hallo - oh I don't
know about that I never played that I
don't know call all your feelings on
that where I didn't like I liked being a
last one alive and going off to a safe
spot to get the respawn yeah I thought
that was a fine system for a fighting
chance
yeah yeah I'm a think it more difficult
like starting back from a checkpoint
yeah that's what like someone else
mentioned
yeah like co-op legendary halo was
always a blast up until five where they
decided not to add it I was a fun wait
not to add what co-op split-screen Oh
split-screen I was like yeah go up was
fun I liked it online but yeah the fact
that it was not couch co-op which you
know like I think in both our minds is
the halo is the pinnacle of that kind of
co-op it was like a staple every game my
buddy and I would play her dead maybe
but halos awesome and and comet evolved
I think is both of our favorite of the
series yeah I like Halo 2 a lot campaign
lives if you think about it doing
legendary on Halo 2 you wouldn't get
past that sniper al you know like a
would generals yeah I would be in
possibly have to use that shortcut over
the roofs okay nope Jesus I thought that
was an open area okay let me I think I
went up there yeah see even this I'm
like no I'm gonna pair my okay
mo mo for my shotgun would be great no
I'm so here's a question now I'll bring
up the chat like regarding hallo just
speaking to me Mike
regarding hallo should it be heroic or
should it be legendary like legendary
like I just I will heroic ass I said I
say heroic because you would that's like
this is pretty much play oh sorry hold
on why would I this is this is right
yeah pretty much
charge burst I don't think I want to
mess around with explosive rounds I
don't know a friendly fire would hurt me
with those I'm six minutes in sweet I
think I'm more than that I would say
heroic I think legendary would not be as
fun to watch cuz heroic like the idea
the show is we want a fighting chance so
it's not just about the dying it's about
the surviving the tension so I think
heroic would still be pretty tough like
you would have to like go into corners
and wait out like a pack of grunts
that's attacking you like grunts impacts
are still pretty dangerous for sure
heroic and this is not even just that
but like halo is still one of those
games I would even compare it to like a
lot of open-world leave Sandboxie games
we're like you can slip and just a
grenade can go off and start changing
you don't need like there's falling
there's chasms and [ __ ] yeah and like
the warthog even when you're driving
under in the tunnels no mercy in the
chat hardest possible period make it
hell for yourself but yeah but I mean
that's if you want to definitely see him
die and I guess if we do ultimately but
I also want to see how far you get I
don't know it's worth talking about we
don't have to worry about it for a few
weeks that's right because we're playing
doom right now with one life as we move
on to another game I'm losing my sense
of direction I think I'm going off this
way this area is a little worried F so
I'm worried it you know obviously on the
harder difficulty I run a bigger chance
of running into a tough enemy if I
explore but I also find more upgrades
yeah
James O'Neill you get a shout out how
are you welcome oh this is this is the
area yeah this was the area last time it
was the explosive barrels yeah I want to
also not talk so much and keep you in
the right mindset I'm fine right now
this game you kind of get into a flow
it's just a matter of something dumb
like those things happening for those
who are wondering why I'm not using
those barrels to kill people it's
because I'm afraid I like cently kill
myself with them I think there's
something down here I didn't I got
shotgun shells and shooting okay
conserve some ammo
oh don't charge that up don't track that
up see I don't think Jesus what hit me
no oh my god
what hit me
no I was doing fine until then what was
that fire someone like from above me I
think shot one of those big things at me
I should have kept moving like I knew I
should have
alright well sweep that was do know how
long was that uh I don't know what sick
I mean let's see we started at 20
minutes 6 15 minutes
sweet I'll go back and figure it out
alright well all we should do is just
hold my second no way damn
is it on yeah yeah it's the HDMI closest
to the power I'm sorry Mike that's a
bummer
that's why I Bruin I should have kept
moving that's what you do and I'm an ice
cream am I talking too much no you were
fine it had nothing to do with it was
nobody's fault but my own for not moving
it did look like I spontaneously
combusted I yeah it was one of those um
your back was to the cliff to it didn't
look like there was a man he might have
been above me or I don't know I I
brought that on myself by I was shooting
the whole time up until then 15 minutes
man it looked like 15 minutes I'll write
that down so here's the thing this is
not I so here's the other thing though
is that like I don't know if we have I
don't know we have Dark Souls remastered
fully downloaded because this is the
list if you're just joining us we put
permadeath in every game oh you already
wrote down how long I survived oh no no
this was some last week I have enough so
I got 19 minutes and 12 seconds in all
right so so legendary sure that's bold I
don't even know if you're gonna make it
off the pillar of autumn I can
I'd say heroic but like heroic or
legendary I want one more one more
opportunity legendary
I don't know I'm just gonna die at some
point yeah I so again that's one for
heroic heroic oh that's one stuff but I
would say I would say heroic as well
Dark Souls remasters after halo heroic
is normal on Halo no it's not shut up in
[Music]
legendary is not heroic is not normal on
Halo it's just the fun way to play it's
a good challenge um I'd say heroic let's
let's go heroic you'll it'll be a decent
challenge and you'll still like get past
the pillar of autumn and see more of the
game do mythic heroic there's a lot of
people saying ik be a legend Oh for the
record Dark Souls I probably you would
die that for that story thing to get
hollowed or whatever if I remember
correctly alright I'll say heroic yeah
heroic
let's go you got like six heroics
I just skipping the intro cutscene if
people don't mind I know this is like we
don't have loaded it should be done by
now yeah okay
it was close it's a short download can
you skip it I think it once it loads and
yeah there you go this is the Master
Chief collection version it is it's
looks worse than I remember oh it is
wait sorry are you playing this isn't
the anniversary so buy anniversary it's
it's a 1080p remaster right it's not
like the original halo on X under
original I thought you're gonna play an
anniversary like the better-looking one
so that's this oh yeah you press back to
look at it yeah which is it looks it
doesn't look right okay alright I'd
rather play like this
today we understand hallo difficulties
you're talking to rob and I what are you
doing
Oh looks alright so here we go
chicken Tate you're supposed to support
us I know I don't I go this one do that
have a light right hurts my light off RV
or L be on this version you're right
wait till you see
the cutscenes like yeah like it having
played this it's just it's crazy how bad
it does captain Jacob use the point of
the show isn't just to die right away
you technically didn't play doom on the
hardest difficulty
no I didn't right I'm agreeing with you
I think heroics good okay oh yes players
alunite died already in doom god that's
a bummer I wanted that is a bummer you
probably skip this if you want think
you're right great thanks
I love the how low the framerate drops
if you just keep mailing a lot out of a
crunch it's not an it's not an hour from
when we start a game it's an hour from
the beginning a live stream Bob so Bob
Jones so 3:06 today we rob land he just
has to survive until then from the
beginning of this yeah when they're
getting up dunes action not this game
animation
yeah it's all trifling with jewels use
one Spanish no just kidding
good for drums yeah it's your muffin top
especially the flood parasites
Eric Green FTL we would die probably too
soon for the show sorry
I mean who knows maybe maybe we'll get
to the end this level if you think it
was too easy we could put it on
legendary but up to you do you feel like
it's I mean I I actually like to be
honest I grenade there there's gonna be
a slip yeah
I'm telling you I like literally when
once you land
I don't forget the name of the mission
once you land it's just halo halo you're
right there's an area where it was so
difficult I was like dude there's
there's no way I can get past and I'm
having played to some legend area I
remember like there are there are
moments where like just it's like trial
and error yeah cuz there's like six
elites on top of those towers oh for
sure like I was running out of health
like I like source health packets in the
game
that's like that [ __ ] you know I'm
talking about yeah your stress a
straggler they'll settle yeah that
always happens new order is a good idea
yeah we might need to start lengthening
the lists since we're in Game three on
week two already you're just buying time
for Dark Souls to download now I'm just
a I think you'll you'll be fine today
but I said that about doing oh [ __ ] yeah
Ben Ben's right our pip is covering the
health bar which we have in halo I guess
if it gets low enough I'll tell people
we can fix that for next time
I don't think we expect it to be I don't
know if hey if taser you can come in and
fix it yeah because that is one of the
things about this game it's uh you have
the health bar they brought that back
for five right I think I can't really
take that away yeah halo 2 you just had
like Call of Duty recharge oh oh yeah
sorry
stop throwing grenades
yeah I agree Bob and Ben will put
pip-pip Bob bottom-right areas high
this isn't this wasn't my fault eh it
burns back that's gonna be it I swear to
god that's how you die it's so off in
this game it was like a bunch of
grenades chain react this mission to
like close quarters this is the end
already I'm this this drop up I think so
you just walk on there there's one more
era area I know what oh that's right you
had way to deplete thanks - thanks hey
you're the best
all right arguing if this is halo or not
no it's not
do ya so if you're just joining us this
is a new show second week of the show
called grave hoppers where we put
permadeath in every game so you die one
so you move on to the next game we have
a list of games I'll pull that up well
maybe we'll pull that up on a loading
screen or something but we are on game 3
I just died in doom that's why we were
playing doom earlier but I didn't do so
well when he was doing fine until I
wasn't when you get scared I get scared
well I can't help it
yeah pretty pretty basic dude kill me
timesplitters would be good I love doing
one of my favorites
oh my god where was that problem you
know scope guy with the m60 pistol yeah
my aim is good without it fountain that
was the case of battle rifles yeah it's
so funny to think about this game in
like just Halo two words like alright
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
take that pistol out because it was so
goddamn overpowered we'll bring it back
later just not yet and we're also gonna
take out the assault rifle because that
was or wasn't it - no it wasn't that was
just so weak yeah for the battle is like
family mediator the snv's works dual
wielding yeah god dude every time you
throw plasma grenade yeah the time
sputters arcade cabinet in a homefront
there's a first like three missions I
believe from time splitters in that
cabinet yep - I don't want to say
anything cuz I honestly don't know
man I regret that dude I should cut
socks alright cuz honestly how long am I
gonna I'll beat the asylum demon I don't
know no I think about that yet so you
would have been playing for you know how
long you've got another like 30 minutes
until the end of the episode okay I can
do that
there's no zip lines in this game so
we're Cooper hood yeah who's joining
this nice throw
[Laughter]
we're not grenade go it's like it's a
dog the treat on his nose absolutely
escape pods get blown up
oh it's a beard yeah doom doom defeated
me
I don't think there's much you can do
about that maybe the only thing was that
you were you were stationary no that's
what it was yeah I shouldn't I shouldn't
stop moving at all even like the health
and armors laid out in that game stuff
to encourage you to keep moving I really
already he laughs but that's how he's
gonna look if he gets stuck with a
grenade oh they're gonna say it was like
what's the come on halo wait what I'll
be is light what'd I just do did you not
apply it did you gotta press a there you
go now we're talking
I'll take your blood oh that's what it
does it does this this is weird addition
to the anniversary when you move makes
print you know it it disengages
automatically it's kind of out actually
don't like it at all that's very
nauseating I dare you to throw a plasma
grenade in here no he just gave me a
panic attack just thinking about that
you get stuck on these like railings
sound like a dog panting
do they see your flashlights I want to
say they do I don't even know
couple elites the first time you fought
to it once I don't know that that I mean
actually maybe three is it they're very
good at dodging grenades I was being
serious first they are no they really
are these guys love elite so much in
Halo 2 there they like added a mechanic
to them where they were just randomly
jump on top of a box and shoot like
they're just made himself easier to
shoot but it was the idea of them just
having that height I don't know they're
just so overly aggressive sometimes okay
you didn't even pass the cryo chamber
again yes right here yeah
I feel like I'm later levels with a
pistol ammo will be a problem frag
grenades were so powerful in this game
yeah
I don't think that can even hurt you can
it I think that's just a show you think
I hope doesn't matter anymore all right
yeah that's how I feel about this level
what all right just all standing there
yeah
goddamn right
like library there's no way I'd get past
that Acuff any any any level with a [ __ ]
excuse me with a rocket launcher from an
enemy I feel like oh yeah yeah no I
think heroics good
[Applause]
I got my my skillful doom run out of the
way I'm on the pilots yeah oh yeah you
didn't die when we were playing that was
just an hour it got like going the right
way
yeah that's it right there
I think you could just get on if you
wanted to
no sorry it's not even that one it's
farther down I guess he's on to the next
game
oh whoa that was so badass all right
first mission done
nice job oh you don't need to save yeah
that's okay we're good Oh when the leads
on the bridge when you get to hail in
the snow levels as a shorts basically
sword sword wheeling elites are
relentless sound like a cartographer is
that the first time you see one inside
it was low me coffee but I died in tomb
yes Doom one okay here we go second
mission halo get all the supplies you
can yep what do you usually do trek
across the bridge you know if you jump
off the bridge on this level you get an
extra ammo you do you cross before the
drop ships get there yeah well the
Banshees to mess if you're looking up
and walked off all right let's get enter
the Chi code
you're gonna leave him sure yeah okay
why no I'm not criticizing you I just
didn't I don't know your strategy
I usually oh I didn't tell you I'm
trying to speedrun this as well okay see
they see you either way the drop ships
are you waste a lot of ammo if you try
to take them out but I'm trying to
member you can't you can't take out drop
ships yes sorry now dropship Saipan jeez
yes and wait alright
you could take out drop ships with the
Scorpion later no there's a halo to it
started you can't take out ghosts either
they don't explode what on earth eat
humming do you not get a scorpion this
game you can destroy do but those do you
only kill the person they never know I
take it back I take it back
I think you're right are you good yeah
y'all dank beats everything
if you bet if you press a pause and save
and quit it gives you a cheat code your
shields got low for the first time all
right you're coming up on first big
fight I'd say you got to help these one
survivors this one this is not an easy
fight heroic I should be okay but in
legend I think that would work so
quickly yeah oh yeah there's no falling
damage in the first game I think there
is or they removed it for the second
year so there was in the first game No
and like I remember the book dammit I
remember in the books they justified the
no falling damage as like his shield
wrapping around the bottom of speech
spread on this assault rifle yeah
welcome to the party did you bring chips
all right there you go
without the ammo and this game comes in
those like zips ziplock bags yeah
just rip it open with your teeth yeah
how many drop ships is it for that you
defend against here you're three how do
you switch your grenade I got Damon RB
whatever button flashlights not be
Oh jackals
frickin kneelers why the shield's not on
we're just not seeing I'm really worried
I'm trying to murmur if there is
following damage in this first game I'm
pretty sure there is I'm pretty sure
there is whatever I know they switch it
between 1 and 2 so they had a ghost mode
they're adding ghost mode to wildlands
Ghost Recon wildlands which is Parma
death the same game like a story mode
yeah and then reloading you get rid of
the bullets you don't use
which is oh the [ __ ] marine shot you
yeah I'm so dumb yeah they are you're
right okay so hallo - they got rid of it
shin splints you check his pulse
alright there's a thing sending two at
the same time or some [ __ ] I think so
yeah Oh kneedler's those are gonna be
terrifying if your health is now I know
we're in halo - the needler just became
way too powerful there was always a gun
that was wit like not just overpowered
but clearly Oh P pistol in this game
Neil earned two carbines pretty good in
all the games actually my favourite
weapon oh that got up there
yeah you know what's gonna be horrifying
is a also assault on the control room
when you're in the tank and there's a
kind of vehicles yeah yeah that's Alessi
your list yeah
nope that would be the shortest run on a
mall so now they said is it too now to
drop ships
yeah
yeah Preston Davis Ghost Recon and the
division are two totally separate teams
each division is massive Ghost Recon is
Ubisoft Paris same publisher but they oh
they have a lot of studios
I thought that laser was a grenade
Foehammer I'm so weird that I'm Donna
from that 70 show becomes the voice and
I was in Halo 2 Foehammer
dies in this game in the end doesn't she
die no somehow she doesn't she gets off
with you guys I think oh no I guess she
would have unless she goes back to about
Johnson was the only one other one who's
alive maybe it's not foam hammer but
either way Donna is your humor there's a
part coming up like right now in the
caves where it's a jump over a chasm you
know what I'm talking about it's it's
easy to get over but it's possible too
short jump it nice
alright he's on to Dark Souls so here's
my question I always ask why didn't you
just get on the dropship and then go to
the next crash site
maybe she explained it I wouldn't be as
fun I realized that and I get it it's
just a fun game but
so it must leave
I hope I don't die from Warthog related
I'm going to use your suits coming out
it's right here at the top of this ramp
oh you go just circles
right there
oh this oh you got the bridge right
coming up should be fine yeah oh man
gone afraid like a Korean age oh that's
yeah that's the dream
yeah Dora the fear and also get office
well I would suggest that yeah AI
Gunners sucked to shoot him first
yeah there we go
I was just about to say I can't wait for
you encounter hunter but they're easy to
kill in this game yeah with the pistols
one shot yeah who knows I mean you could
slip though thank you
yeah there's sometimes a card game
Smasher it is 253 p.m. Pacific in
America tying to a Marine would be good
if I grenade or something man they're
such long struggles Oh God
suck it oh geez you look at a health
they're two of them to health parts down
he's not he's just a man yeah are they
dead did the turret gunner kill them or
they actually did something nice this
was cool back then but this is such a
long drawn-out walk yeah I know what I'm
doing
yep I know what I'm doing
SiC bridge
all right take a little shortcut here
same time mission after this is silent
cartographer right there know it sorry
Truth and Reconciliation is that the
stealth operation one sniper yeah it's
very good but yeah it could be dangerous
art side that would be bad
and then sandwich orthography and then
assault my controller than 343 Guilty
Spark library two betrayals no keys
first no yeah he's two betrayals the mom
there's nine in this game right and then
halo to go the halo halo two's campaign
is like an extra seven hours yeah it's
long we should add a post-mortem to the
grave hoppers line up graphic in what
way because we do we are recording the
times we survive in each game crane this
twitch if you're not in twitch that's in
the twitch chat also we kind of also
have the highlight reel that I cut every
time so the beginning of each episode
when these turn into vods you'll be able
to catch up in about two minutes on the
previous step so you have a certain
order you do the drop ships in
it was crazy like the first time I
played this game I like oh you have to
in this order but then my friends like
oh I do this I do this the one on the
cliff with the sniper rifle first that's
the one I do last me doing right in the
cliff side right yeah it's like the big
filled with rocks along a cliff side
that one I think it's just the one with
this it's like a kind of like a
deathtrap up on the on the rocks
I think this one is that wrong I'm
thinking of I think yeah this is yeah
that's that one there's rocks in the
middle yeah there's a sniper rifle near
the dropship yeah there is I don't like
this one as much
shoot yeah high for me as you're facing
the wrong way
stalker cheb shut up Chernobyl will be
pretty scary pretty dated game but still
good
minesweeper should I was nervous today I
can't imagine going into the dark side
if we even get there it's Australian
friend what is you looking at I'm but
tumblr you guys are on your own I'm
gonna be up here secluded get up
yeah catastrophic is Dark Souls
remastered on ps4 I recently played
probably 60 something for Dark Souls
yeah yikes
next I'm not sure pretty well
you pretty much have to sniper rifles
now match to hey just go straight
through the shield's right I don't and
they maybe they break
I thought you were smart when someone
else again mentioned fallout for
survival mode that would be a good one
yeah
just cuz you can put yourself in such
crazy situations where you just run out
of ammo and like ya trying to get out of
a location right like sewers yeah
person song is we were playing doom but
uh this is grave hoppers where we have
permit death in every game so I died in
tomb and we moved on to halo the next
game on our list if Rob is to die before
oh you have 7 more minutes
nice awesome health if Rob survives the
next seven minutes he continued to the
halo next week if he dies I play dark
souls until I die never waste a sniper
on a grunt
go
perfect dark zero and I played a lot of
that more than I should have oh six
minutes left you have six minutes left
not like this no thanks no thank you
oh you escaped dirty health up here
no nice throw I thought that got him you
get the other one maybe yeah they're all
charging you they know what you're
playing grave hoppers those elites or
just jackal like I'm not gonna go for
that health now yeah five minutes
definitely not gonna beat the mission I
don't think can you hard saving this
yeah you save and quit and it'll go back
to the last checkpoint just get will
just go to the next checkpoint okay oh
man I get XCOM would be interesting we
would have to like start how do you mean
know how that would work
I just because I thought the brag but I
don't know if that foul missions until
late in the game we would have to like
we could pick one character that we make
in XCOM and have them survive or like
for I don't know that becomes because if
they get injured they're gonna be in the
infirmary for like a week depending on
their injury yeah four minutes cliff
edge is the one with the buildings
inside Oh
who wants to die
get the heart I there's no horn right
Alec you know not in this town
all right well maybe go to the next one
what's uh the next one from here would
be the cliff face right I don't know if
you came back to this entrance Abbi
oh yeah this is the one I'm thinking of
this is my brand lucky right yeah you go
dunzo Washington come on that was a
split second nice it's that two times
zoom you got a you almost did it then
you kill background with sniper I guess
the next checkpoint officially close out
the episode whoa
you haven't gotten down to read yet
you got into yellow a couple times we be
doing pretty quickly I will agree I'm
trying to pay attention see when you get
a checkpoint
you want to check one or how about a
compete this one yeah sure that's
probably safer bet
I'm not safer but oh it for a checkpoint
what no nice shot
you've got an Oscar pedis wasting ammo
that was it I think so
all right I guess wait until a
checkpoint did you get one are you sure
I don't know I would go go uh back
toward the river that's the thing about
this game checkpoints were pretty uh
capricious I always wish you could jump
on there quickly to get the hell yeah
health would be good and then he could
say then quit once you get to the
checkpoint you might have already got
one I wasn't positive but just to be
safe so the last one is the cliff and
then you go to truth and reconciliation
stealth mission I forgot how much reach
mirrored this game the campaign oh we
got a checkpoint from the Pelican Bob
downside I didn't see well that's just
saving done really quick well we'll get
a checkpoint upon driving where's the
egg now there you go there you go oh
sweet yeah save and quit so that was I'm
not gonna feel good about that for the
whole weekend thanks for joining us
that's gonna be it
I had a good time makes one of us
oh that was that was rough that was
tough this is not up to date I don't say
like what 1912
it will also say heroic 19 minutes and
12 seconds okay on doom ultraviolence
but that's gonna do it I got cocky you
guys know I did the opposite I should
have been more you should have been more
cocky which is odd for me it's very odd
so yeah next episode could be all halo
for the whole hour if Rob survives the
rest of the this mission called halo or
you probably get through the
reconciliation they can be kind of long
depending how careful you are there's
some tricky parts and but we'll see
sound a cartographer that's right solve
them a control room 343 Guilty Spark
yeah I don't think I'll get past library
library
I don't assault on control rooms gonna
be tough with the vehicles and the
potential for that stuff yeah I agree
anyway thanks everybody for joining as
always yeah and if you have any
suggestions on games we'll need them put
them in the comments we keep going at
this rate yeah that as well as you know
we might revise some of these if you
look back it's all subject to change
that's gonna do I think you guys so much
have a great rest of the week have a
great weekend
have a great life bye
[Music]